bueno Y tenemos que cerrar la semana
también hablando de economía y hablando
de los bancos Jorge muy buenas noches
Tenemos que hablar del Dodge Bank que
sufrió una caída en sus acciones del
8,5% reafirmando entonces esa inquietud
a nivel internacional por la estabilidad
de los sistemas financieros en el mundo
y esto Pese a que las autoridades
monetarias y gubernamentales llevan días
insistiendo en que el sistema financiero
europeo es sólido los inversores siguen
nerviosos sobre todo porque la crisis y
su venta forzosa hay lluvias siguen
presentes la capitalización del banco
alemán sigue cayendo actualmente ronda
los 18 mil millones de euros y desde la
quiebra del silicon ha perdido en bolsa
más de un 25% de todo su valor Los
indicadores más amplios de la atención
en los mercados financieros también se
dispararon el euro cayó frente al Dólar
los rendimientos de la deuda pública de
la zona Euro se fueron a la baja y
muchos comparan esta crisis del crédito
suite con el banco alemán porque los dos
bancos son símbolos financieros de los
respectivos países también llevan mucho
tiempo la mira de los reguladores se
financiaron con inversores del Golfo
Pérsico y sus acciones llevan algún
tiempo a la baja eso sí entre las
diferencias está el tamaño el Dodge Band
es el octavo mayor banco europeo
Mientras que el Credit Suite era el
décimo séptimo pasemos ahora entonces a
los indicadores Cómo se comportaron las
bolsas hoy Bueno vamos a empezar en
Europa en este mercado cerró en negativo
el índice de stocks europe 600 que
agrupa a los principales bancos europeos
que hay un 3,78% empujado por estas
pérdidas en el sector bancario en
Estados Unidos las bolsas cerraron al
alza marcando el final de también una
semana turbulenta en la que las
autoridades de la reserva Federal
calmaron los temores sobre una posible
crisis de liquidez en el sector bancario
y en América Latina el índice de
referencia de la bolsa de Sao Paulo el
ivo Vespa avanzó un 0,92% dejando atrás
la volatilidad de los últimos días Provo
por la decisión del Banco Central de ese
país de mantener los tipos de interés
altísimos en el 13,75% Jorge mientras
esto tiene lugar y toda esta
incertidumbre a nivel bancario está es
común alrededor del mundo los líderes
europeos se reúnen en Bruselas Qué
dijeron sobre este tema Bueno
principalmente restaron importancia del
riesgo de estas recientes turbulencias
financieras mundiales que podrían
provocar una crisis bancaria que afecte
la economía de Europa los jefes de
gobierno de la Unión Europea afirmaron
que los bancos europeos gozan de buena
salud y están en condiciones de escapar
de una combinación de su vida de tipos
de interés y una ralentización del
crecimiento económico escuchamos
el modelo de negocio de Dodge sea
modernizado y reorganizado y es un banco
muy rentable no hay motivos para
preocuparse por nada
los fundamentos de los bancos europeos
son sólidos y podemos alegrarnos de que
nuestra Norma sea exigente en este
sentido hemos aprendido de las crisis
pasadas la eurozona es hoy la zona donde
los bancos son más sólidos porque se
siguen de la manera más escrupulosa los
ratios bancarios tanto de solvencia como
de liquidez que salieron de la crisis
financiera de 2008 a 2010 Jorge hablemos
de proyecciones como las que presentó el
fondo monetario internacional sobre
Panamá un país a propósito lleno de
bancos el fmi afirma que pese a una
recuperación económica muy fuerte ahora
las perspectivas son inciertas Panamá se
enfrenta a los riesgos de nuevos choques
externos así como probables
interrupciones en la minería del cobre
porque aún no logra renovar un acuerdo
común la minera de Panamá otro de los
riesgos es la inclusión de Panamá en la
lista Gris del grupo de acción
financiera internacional según el banco
Panamá tiene que hacer los esfuerzos
para salir pronto de esta lista Jorge y
tenemos que hablar de Centroamérica
porque hay un producto muy particular la
piña rosada que es producida en Costa
Rica deliciosa hay que decirlo toma fama
en los mercados internacionales esta
exótica variedad marca tendencia global
y desde Costa Rica se aumentan los
envíos hacia Estados Unidos Canadá
emiratos árabes Unidos
Qatar kuwai Hong Kong entre otros en la
piña rosada nació tras 17 años de
investigación en los laboratorios de la
empresa Fresh del monte una compañía
emblemática en Costa Rica que
comercializa fruta a nivel mundial esta
variedad de piña genéticamente
modificada fue aprobada por la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de Estados Unidos para su
consumo y salió a la venta hace muy poco
en el año 2020 en 2003 la empresa
comenzó un proceso de investigación de
bioingen para alterar la genética de la
fruta que normalmente es color amarillo
hasta conseguir que naturalmente
creciera de color rosado la exótica piña
se puede comprar en Estados Unidos por
un precio de entre 11 a 39 dólares por
unidad y en España puede llegar a costar
hasta 36 dólares escuchemos lo que
decían en parte de los directivos de
esta empresa sobre esta producción la
piña rosé fue obtenida por técnicas de
bioingeniería es decir usamos el
laboratorio como un método alternativo
al procedimiento convencional de cruces
con polen Bueno y con esto ponemos punto
final a la economía Muchas gracias Jorge
a continuación en directo América ya
viene una semana en el mundo